alors ça donne ça soit rasé montfort la
comédie musicale on pense oui moi je
suis tu nous as rogers telus et fred
astaire master ou jim kelly ça dépend
des moments
sens nerveux
à soi
je
les chats pour faire le numéro du far
west
[Musique]
shirley et dino sur scène en dur
nul besoin de trop de costumes juste
quelques accessoires et des milliers de
payet shirley et dino artiste
multifacettes chanteur à leurs danseurs
ou magiciens peu importe les ingrédients
leur recette est efficace elle séduit
depuis dix ans de l'imagination du
talent tout simplement pas maintenant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
trop plaisir prothésiste c'est possible
j'aime bien passé c'est beau j'aime
faire des regards de visite ça sa place
on est les muscles et ma cousine
on voit bien le triceps
on dirait un filet mignon on fait un
petit peu de tout et surtout enfin un
petit peu de rien beaucoup de voix là
mais on en est conscient mais comment on
y met tout notre coeur
les gens ils trouvent ça bien c'est ça
les artistes de music-hall hier sous
chapiteau entourée d'artistes en tous
genres aujourd'hui les yeux dans les
yeux sur la scène feutré du théâtre
marigny en quelques années
achille tonic la troupe est devenu duo
un cousin et une cousine touche-à-tout
complices dans la grande tradition du
music hall
le public adore de succès en succès ils
atteignent désormais la notoriété
[Musique]
l'ebit cité il reste simple rien n'a
changé
tant mieux juste pour le plaisir s'il
vous plaît encore un rien mais c'est pas
de tout repos
[Musique]